Transcriber: Alber Makhoul
المدقّق: gaith Takrity
السلام عليكم.
هل تجدون أن التطوع الصحي أنقذ حياة شخص؟
تابعوا معي اليوم لنعرف قصة هذا الشخص سويةً
التطوع الصحي هو صورة
من صور التطوع الإحترافي
والتي أتى في رؤية المملكة
في 2030 والتي تطمح للوصول
لمليون متطوع احترافي
في المملكة إن شاء الله.
من أمثلة التطوع الصحي، بشكل عام
ما أتى في بداية جائحة كورونا،
حيث شارف تقريباً
قرابة أربعمائة ألف متطوع
للحد من جائحة كورونا
والحد من انتشار فيروس كورونا
أيضاً من الأمثلة العامة
للتطوع الصحي الاحترافي
ما تقوم به المؤسسات الصحية والمستشفيات
حالياً في المستشفيات الحكومية والخاصة.
المبادرات والحملات التطوعية الاحترافية
مثل حملات التطوع بالتوعية بسرطان القولون.
سرطان الثدي
التوعية بالأمراض المزمنة مثل مرض السكري
ضغط الدم
الفشل الكلوي أمراض كثيرة مزمنة.
وهذه كلها أمثلة عن التوعية
الصحية الاحترافية.
لذا في ذلك الزمن.
في بداية الرؤية تم تأسيس منصة...
منصة التوعية الصحية
وهي منصة إلكترونية تهدف لتسجيل المتطوعين
وتوصيلهم وربطهم باللجان
والعاملين في المجال
التطوعي في الميدان لتأهيل وتسهيل
وصول المتطوعين إلى الميدان.
هل تدرون أن سرطان القولون يعتبر الأول
إصابة للرجال والثالث بالنسبة للنساء
مع وجود جهود مبذولة كثيرة
من الجهات المختصة
وهي حاضرة بوجود مراكز متخصصة
ووجود برنامج وطني
وهو البرنامج الوطني للكشف
المبكر عن سرطان القولون
إلا أن المجتمع لا يعي ذلك ولا يزال
يحتاج لمواكبة وتحقيق أهداف
هذا البرنامج الوطني
لذا التطوع الصحي الاحترافي
وجد مع جهود الدولة
في القطاعات الحكومية والخاصة
لسد هذه الفجوة ما بين وجود البرنامج
ونقص وعي المجتمع
لتحقيق أهداف هذا البرنامج
والذي انطلق من أسفل مظلة وزارة الصحة
دعوني أقدم لكم قصة هذا الشخص
مريض أتى إلينا للمستشفى
يبلغ من العمر أربعة وخمسين سنة
أتى مرافقاً مع زوجته
لإحدى  العيادات داخل المستشفى
وكان هناك حملة توعوية صحية هدفها الأساسي
التوعية بسرطان القولون.
أثناء الحملة و أعمال الحملة والحديث معه
كان يتكلم بكل شفافية بكل أريحية
لا يملك أدنى فكرة عن مرض سرطان
القولون وخطورته
إلى أي مدى يمكن لهذا المرض أن يكون فتاكاً
بعد جلوس الفريق الطبي
والحديث معه بدأ يتفهم الوضع
بدأ يفهم أن الموضوع فيه خطورة
يوجد احتمال الإصابة أي شخص
حتى لو لم يكن لديه أية أعراض
وبحسب معايير البرنامج الوطني للفحص المبكر
والتي انطبقت على هذا الشخص
حددنا له موعداً، لعمل تنظير للقولون،
وهنا كانت المفاجأة، عندما أجرى التنظير
وجدنا ورم في نهاية القولون،
في منطقة تدعى القولون السيني شكله كان
مريباً أخذنا أكثر من عينة من الورم
وبعد عدة أيام وجدنا أن الورم هذا ورم خبيث
من النوع الشرس للقولون
و هو يعرف باسم “Poorly differentiated
adenocarcinoma of the colon”
كان الموضوع صادم بالنسبة للمريض.
جلسنا معه،
أخبرناه بحقيقة الموضوع.
تقبل الموضوع في البداية بصدمة
وهو أمر متوقع من هذا المريض
لم يكن يشتكي من أي أعراض يمارس حياته
بكل شفافية وبشكل طبيعي
فجأة أصيب بهذا المرض أعطيناه الأمل
أعطيناه الطرق العلاجية المتوفرة
ضمن المنشآت الحكومية المؤهلة
شعر باحتمال الشفاء بفضل
المنشآت الحكومية بعد فضل الله
وتقبل فكرة إكمال الإجراءات
العلاجية والتشخيصية والخطة العلاجية،
وبعد ذلك أكملنا إجراءات الفحص
أجرينا القليل من التحاليل والأشعة
وبعدها عرضنا الحالة
على المجلس العلمي للأورام.
بعد ذلك تطورت حالة المريض
وكان لابد من إجراء
عملية استئصال للورم من القولون
أو بالأصح لاستئصال القولون بالكامل.
فقمنا باستئصال الجزء السيني من القولون
وبعد ذلك استمرينا بمتابعة المريض في إحدى
المنشآت الحكومية المؤهلة
في المنطقة الغربية
أخذ الأدوية اللازمة
بعد ذلك تم العلاج الكيميائي
والحمد الله قبل شهر من الآن
زارنا الحمد لله، في العيادة وكان
بكامل صحته وعافيته وكان يشكر الله أولاً
ويشكر الجهود المبذولة
داخل المنشآت الحكومية.
هذا مثال بسيط لما يسمى بنظرية التغيير
البسيط أو “المارجنال أدجسمنت.”
كيف أن حملة توعوية صحية احترافية من
منسوبي وزارة الصحة
كانت تهدف إلى رفع الوعي الصحي.
في النهاية أدى ذلك إلى إنقاذ
حياة هذا الشخص.
السعودية اليوم تعد من العشرة الأوائل في
أعداد المصابين بمرض السكري في العالم
ومن هذا المنطلق في عام 2013
بعد مشاورات بين الزملاء
اتجهنا للجهات المختصة وبالتنسيق معهم
قررنا القيام بمبادرة توعوية صحية
هدفها نشر الوعي
عن مرض السكري.
حيث ممكن أن يكون المريض حاملاً للمرض
ولا يملك إلا أعراض طفيفة جداً لا ينتبه لها
أو لا يدرك المرض إلا بعد حدوث المضاعفات
وما نطمح إليه
هو إيقاف تدهور المرض أو إبطاء عملية
حدوث المضاعفات قدر المستطاع
فبعد التواصل مع الجهات المختصة قررنا
القيام بالحملة واخترنا المكان
التجهيزات كانت جيدة، كان الحضور جداً ممتاز
استلهمنا فكرة البساطة في التقديم
حاولنا تبسيط المعلومة قدر المستطاع للجمهور
استعبدنا فكرة المادة العلمية المعقدة
من أجل تسهيل وصول المعلومة للجميع.
الحمد لله لكم حرية التخيل لكثافة
الجمهور وتفاعلهم مع الحملة.
بعد هذه الجهود كاملة تحقق بعد فضل من الله
توج في نهاية الحملة
اسم المملكة العربية السعودية
بكسر حاجز التسعة آلاف عملية قياس
لمرضى سكري، في يوم واحد، خلال ثمانية ساعات
وسجل الرقم باسم المملكة العربية السعودية
ممثلة بالمنطقة الغربية
في موسوعة غينيس للأرقام القياسية
وأوكد لكم وجود مثل هذه المبادرات
داخل المملكة
على أرض الواقع في جميع أرجاء المملكة
وهذا يدل ويعكس فهم
ووعي المتطوعين الصحيين
وجهودهم المبذولة في نشر
الوعي الصحي بشكل عام.
وكما يقال: استدامة الأعمال
التطوعية تعد دليلاً على النجاح.
وأخيراً أستطيع قول أن التطوع علمني عن
إمكانية تصحيح الكثير من الأخطاء المغلوطة
والإشاعات الخاطئة، وهذا دليل
واضح من خلال المبادرات الصحية.
علمني التطوع أنه يمكن تقليل الإصابة
بالأمراض الخطيرة والفتّاكة
بزيادة الوعي الصحي المجتمعي.
علمني التطوع أنه يمكن أن يكون وسيلة
لزيادة ثقافتك وسعة إدراكك
علمني التطوع أنه يمكن أن يكون
وسيلة للعمل الجماعي كفريق واحد.
علمني التطوع أنه يمكن أن يمنحك فرصة ومساحة
للتعامل مع الآخرين وصقل
مهارات القيادة لديك مع الزمن.
علمني التطوع المعنى الحقيقي للآية الكريمة
“ومن تطوع خيراً فهو خير له.”
فهو خير له... فالتطوع الخيري
هو منطلق ديني والتزام وطني
وهذا ما تدعو إليه رؤية المملكة 2030
شكرا لإنصاتكم.